ministre cours d'examen au sénat la
proposition de loi présentée par
stéphanie rice vous étiez engagé à venir
nous présenter les ordonnances de la loi
santé qui interagissent et fortement ce
texte
cette audition n'a pas été possible au
cours de la période
le sénat consacre ou contrôler
l'application des lois les ordonnances
ont d'ailleurs paru pour la plupart
après le 31 mars après plusieurs reports
de la durée d'habilitation du
gouvernement allait prendre
entre temps beaucoup de choses se sont
passées depuis votre dernière audition
devant une autre commission le 12
janvier dernier
les sujets d'intérêt se sont multipliés
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité qu'on
puisse y consacrer du temps à les
exposer notre commission en particulier
la mise en oeuvre du ségur de la santé
qui a suscité beaucoup d'attentes mais
aussi peut-être pour ces mêmes raisons
certaines déceptions et c'est vrai nous
sommes largement sollicités sur le
territoire par rapport aux suites
données aux ségur nous avons l'occasion
aussi de faire quelques auditions de la
commission
avec les mêmes constats donc voilà donc
le côté je vous souhaite tout de suite
la parole pour vous puissiez nous dira
un peu en année par rapport aux suites
données aux silures à ce qui a été fait
à des choses éventuellement en attente
de promesses données des promesses
tenues ou pas encore tenu voilà je
laisse la parole est ensuite mes
collègues mais président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs suis très
heureux de procéder à un bilan d'étape
de la loi relative à l'organisation et
la transformation du système de santé la
fameuse loi aux tss c'était une loi
attendue depuis longtemps par les
professionnels de santé par nos
concitoyens qui avaient peu à peu perdu
confiance dans un système de santé qui
avait longtemps été considéré comme le
meilleur système de santé au monde la
loi aux tss je le rappelle elle s'est
appuyée sur des constats partagés
elle est toute entière guidés par des
objectifs qui eux aussi sont partagées
par à peu près tout le monde à savoir
adapter les formations et les métiers
aux nouveaux enjeux lutter contre les
déserts médicaux garantir un meilleur
accès de proximité aux soins pour les
français mieux orienter les patients
selon leurs besoins
accroître la qualité et la pertinence
des soins et recourir davantage au
numérique pour mieux soigner
nous avons fait le choix de concentrer
sur deux axes prioritaires
tout d'abord redonner du temps médical
qui consiste à permettre aux médecins de
faire ce pour quoi ils ont été formés
pour ce pourquoi ils sont les mieux
qualifiés sans perdre de temps précieux
à des tâches qui peuvent être déléguées
et deuxième priorité accélérer le
décloisonnement du système de santé
parce que l'exercice isolé doit devenir
l'exception l exercice coordonné une
forme de normes
ces deux axes structurants de la loi tss
doivent permettre de transformer notre
système de santé dans son ensemble
son organisation son financement mais
aussi la formation des futurs
professionnels ou les conditions
d'exercice avec cette loi nous chargeons
de modèles et d'horizon on privilégie le
collectif c'est tout le sens des
communautés professionnelles de
territoire de santé les fameuses cpts au
cours de mes déplacements j'ai constaté
à chaque fois la réussite de ces
structures dans la réponse apportée aux
besoins de santé dans l'épanouissement
des professionnels qui sont heureux de
leur travail et qui retrouve davantage
de sens dans ce qu'ils font et être
heureux dans son travail je ne sais pas
si c'est révolutionnaire mais en tout
cas c'est plutôt indispensable l'une des
avancées majeures de cette loi c'est
aussi d'avoir supprimé la paces et le
numerus clausus qui structurait une
formation en décalage complet avec les
besoins de la démographie médicale c'est
une formidable machine à empêcher des
jeunes médecins de faire médecine en
france
quand en même temps d'aller chercher des
médecins étrangers ou des médecins
français formés à l'étranger pour venir
dans nos campagnes
cette réforme mise en place depuis
septembre dernier a connu quelques
difficultés je ne doute pas que la ville
nous y reviendrons mais le gouvernement
est pleinement engagé à accompagner les
universités et les étudiants dans sa
mise en oeuvre
j'en viens maintenant à des aspects un
peu plus technique je m'en excuse mais
on va pas parler d' à toi la loi aux tss
sans évoquer la structuration de l'offre
de soins dans les territoires c'est
notamment le cas des pts les projets
territoriaux de santé prévue par la loi
qui permette à l'ensemble des acteurs de
la ville de l'hôpital du médico social
de partager un diagnostic et de définir
conjointement des priorités et des
objectifs de ce point de vue là la crise
a été un accélérateur à c'est assez
incroyable puisque de fait aujourd'hui
vous avez des cellules territoriales et
qui s'organise et qui ont pris
l'habitude de travailler ensemble de se
retrouver toutes les semaines ou tous
les mois vous il y avait les ordres
professionnels et syndicats libéraux les
hôpitaux les cliniques la rs qui est
aussi présente et qui a réussi à être à
structurer cette forme de dialogue
opérationnel c'est aussi je crois
l'occasion de créer une culture
soignante par delà les chapelles et les
petits murs parfois artificielles dont
notre système de santé a beaucoup
souffert en parlant de projet de
territoire l'une des avancées du projet
de loi concernant le secteur sanitaire
c'était la création des hôpitaux de
proximité saluer je crois par tous ici
en tout cas vu le nombre de demandes de
parlementaires de tous bords à
l'assemblée au sénat que je reçois qui
porte sur le développement des hôpitaux
de proximité je me dis en tout cas que
l'outil a trouvé sa cible ou à défaut le
coeur des parlementaires
ces hôpitaux ont vocation à être
pleinement ancré dans leur territoire
avec des partenariats forts une
ouverture indispensable sur la ville et
le médico social
c'est une réponse forte à une attente
des professionnels et de nos concitoyens
d'avoir ces structures de proximité
identifié accessible opérationnel j'ai
parlé des murs artificiels
il ya un instant ses murs la loi aux tss
les a fait tomber ou et les arts aux
jambes et dans le champ des compétences
des professionnels de santé
je pense ici notamment au pharmacien
correspondant au protocole de
coopération au développement des
infirmiers de pratiques avancées suis
pleinement convaincu par ses objectifs
de décloisonnement entre les
professionnels de santé et avec le sigle
de la santé j'ai souhaité poursuivre ce
mouvement en lançant vous le savez une
réflexion sur la place et l'opportunité
d'une profession médicale intermédiaire
entre le bac + 3 à bac + 10 je grossis
le trait c'est une exception française
et d'avoir très peu de professions entre
ces deux niveaux de formation et de
compétences enfin la loi aux tss porter
l'ambition d'accélérer les innovations
et le numérique en santé avec la
création du groupe data web dont la
vocation est de favoriser l'utilisation
des données de santé dans les domaines
de la recherche du pilotage du système
de santé
l'information des patients c'est aussi
le cas de l'espace numérique de santé un
compte personnel en ligne qui permettra
à compter du 1er janvier 21 à tous les
français d'accéder à leur dossier
médical partagé très facilement
je ne peux pas parler de numérique sans
parler de télésanté avec le bond en
avant absolument exceptionnelles
réalisées pendant la crise sanitaire je
vous le rappelle on est passé de 10
mille à un million de téléconsultation
par semaine dans notre pays une réponse
pertinente et efficace qui ne remplacera
jamais la relation entre le soignant et
son patient mais qui permet de suppléer
dans un certain nombre de situations et
de gommer les distances géographiques
l'isolément l'éloignement pouvoir le
désert médical la loi aux tss n'est pas
un objet fils fille j'ai posé là une
bonne fois pour toute et d'autres
engagements sont venus l'enrichir et la
compléter je pense ici aux concertations
de l'été dernier et vous avez cité
madame la présidente avec l'ensemble des
acteurs du système de santé dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé on va y
revenir
j'évoquerai
ici les revalorisations salariales hors
norme
les investissements santé 19 milliards
entre la reprise de dettes et
l'investissement hospitalier du jamais
vu et la médicalisation de la
gouvernance qui était très attendu nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion de débattre sur
ces sujets notamment dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi de stéphanie rist qui
a abordé des thématiques telles que la
restauration du service à l'hôpital
la liberté d'organisation interne et de
gouvernance pour les établissements
sortira dans quelques semaines le guide
clarisse que j'ai confiée à olivier
clarisse présidence m e de bordeaux et
qui mettra à disposition des hôpitaux
une boîte à outils pour que s'engage les
négociations les concertations locales
en vue de déterminer les organisations
les plus à même de satisfaire l'ensemble
des professionnels hôpital par hôpital
je cite aussi la meilleure association
des soignants et des usagers la
gouvernance et la lutte effrénée contre
l'intérim médicale nous sommes à la
veille d un an du ségur de la santé les
évolutions réglementaires sont
maintenant une réalité je le dis avec de
la vence par rapport aux engagements que
nous avions signé avec les syndicats
notamment ce qui concerne les
revalorisations et nous n'avons pris de
retard dans aucun des domaines pour
lesquels nous étions engagés
je réunis en ce moment même un an
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
madame la présidente signataires des
organisations signataires du ségur de la
santé j'ai reçu au cours des derniers
jours pour les soignants non-médicaux
force ouvrière puis l'unsa
puis la cfdt toutes trois signataires je
peux vous confirmer qu'aucune de ces
centrales bien au contraire n'a exprimé
le moindre regret quant au soutien
qu'ils ont apporté aux ségur c'est dur
dont le périmètre ensuite à évoluer à
deux reprises au cours de la mission de
laforcade permettant d'englober de plus
en plus d'acteurs de la fonction
publique hospitalière mais est calé mais
également des établissements privés non
lucratifs je le redis les syndicats
m'ont confirmé qu'ils étaient satisfaits
et heureux de leur signature et nous
avons sont trés bien avec j'ai reçu
également les syndicats de praticiens
hospitaliers il ya quelques jours voir
peut-être même cette semaine je
pardonnez moi je suis un peu perdu dans
les dates qui m'ont confirmé aide
également le souhait de conforter la
signature qu'ils ont posés sur les
accords du ségur de sorte que les
accords majoritaires s'il devait être
signé un an après le serait toujours ça
veut pas dire
tout le monde la présidente se satisfait
du ségur et je note que la cgt et sud
restent opposés aujourd'hui aux accords
du ségur on peut on peut l'entendre
comme étant une insuffisance on peut
aussi considérer que nous avons là
malgré tout des organisations
majoritaires
je vois la défunte à grands traits la
loi aux tss dans ses fondements dans sa
mise en oeuvre
avec une ambition profond de transformer
essentiellement les soins de ville dans
une approche transversale pour aboutir à
des soins coordonnés avec un parcours du
patient évolue et vont démarrer ont
démarré des négociations
conventionnelles dans le champ de la
médecine libérale
mais d'autres professions d'ailleurs que
médicales
dans la continuité le ségur de la santé
a permis d'enclencher de réelle
transformation de l'hôpital avec une
nouvelle méthode de construction et de
décloisonnement important vous le voyez
régulièrement je suis pleinement engagé
dans la mise en place en application de
la stratégie ma santé 2022 et du ségur
conformément aux engagements qui ont été
pris je très attaché à ce que ces
travaux majeurs permettent effectivement
de transformer notre système de santé
que cela se traduise concrètement pour
les français je sais que ces thèmes vous
sont très chers et le sénat avait
beaucoup travaillé et enrichi ce projet
de loi nous sommes là pour voir ensemble
où il en est aujourd'hui j'en suis très
heureux je vous remercie
très bien merci monsieur mine et sans
nouvelles
beaucoup de questions donc on va fermer
des blogs de questions et je vais
d'abord passer la parole à rené paul
savary ensuite fait les mouiller la
présidente de
quatre thèmes que je souhaite aborder
rapidement donc l'espace numérique de
santé qui va être adossée au dossier
médical partagé est une avancée que nous
préconisions déjà depuis un certain
temps puisqu'elle permettra notamment
d'avoir une coordination des actes
médicaux par rapport aux patients
puis les applications c'est un moyen
moderne qui permet effectivement
d'éviter des acteurs demandant de
prendre en compte bon êtes vous bien
prêt pour le 1er juin
c'est le 1er juillet que ça doit être
2022 d'accord parce que là vous avez du
1er janvier 2021 ce passage savais pas
avant je croyais que c'était le 1er
juillet en juillet 2021
donc est-ce que le ça tient bien la
route les outils seront ils prêts pour
qu'il y ait une vraie appropriation de
cet espace numérique de de santé par les
patients et puis bien sûr par les
professionnels de santé il ya un certain
nombre de dossier médical partagé
maintenant qu'ils sont là mais qui sont
pas des encore efficace il ya une
collection de données mais il n'y a pas
il n'ya pas justement toute cette ce
partage de données qui peut être
intéressant deuxième point lepreau sur
le plan de la réanimation et notamment
la formation des médecins réanimateurs
intensif intensifs on en a formé que 74
que deux plus et on voit bien que c'est
quand même une profession qui a une
reconnaissance depuis 2010 est qui est
tout à fait utile en temps de crise est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que nous
pourrions former davantage compte tenu
que les organismes de formation sont
disponibles nous les avons reçus et nous
ont dit que l'encadrement pouvait être
suffisant pour en former davantage
peut-être qu'il faut modifier la
répartition des postes internes pour
tenir compte de la crise que nous venons
de connaître troisième point même si
c'est pas directement liées aux os ségur
mais on a connu une crise et qui a
modifié encore un certain nombre de
choses
la vaccination notamment la vaccination
des soignants
vous avez je crois pris une position en
disant que peut-être il sera nécessaire
de venir vers l'obligation si on n'a pas
suffisamment de soignants enfin j'ai cru
qu'on prend merci de clarifier la
position et nous faire un état des lieux
de la vaccination des soignants parce
que je pense que c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait déterminant 1 par rapport à
la confiance qu'on peut avoir dans notre
système de santé
et puis quatrième point vous avez
monsieur le ministre reconnu les
avancées du travail du sénat dans cette
loi et notamment nous avions proposé que
dans le cas de la lutte contre la
désertification médicale les
ces étudiants de 9e année de troisième
année de troisième cycle puisse aller
pendant au moins six mois sur le terrain
faire un rôle de médecin généraliste de
façon à pouvoir l'a aussi amené à mener
un service dans certains territoires en
difficulté ce que les décrets ont été
pris est ce que cette mesure est en
application
c'était peut-être que nous l'avions même
voté un plfss je sais plus si la mesure
nous l'avions telle mesure de soirée
bien derrière la voilà et je crois qu'il
ya besoin d'un décret mais je n'en suis
pas persuadé mais est ce que la mesure
étend l'application voilà et bien même
sans décret est ce que la mesure est en
application mais nous nous sommes crois
pas mais
phil est mouillé oui merci au nom de ce
ministre
moi j'ai boutou abordé le volet
médico-social
ma première question concerne bien
entendu le laissiez de réalisation
salariales dans le secteur médico-social
et on est en même temps la mission qui a
été confiée à michel laforcade donc dans
ces camps d'orientation alors la clé
soit simple c'est un scoop et nous
posent ils périmètre puisqu'il lui dise
évolution dans le temps concernant le
périmètre dans lequel man ans s'applique
ces mesures si de relation salariale et
notamment à la fois dans le domaine du
secteur public et du secteur privé
et quelles incidences financières ça
c'est la première question deuxième
question ça concerne la partie des
délégations de crédit d'investissement
sur secteur médico social
on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de travaux qui
de réfection qui sont menées qui ont été
portées ici au sénat mais également un
certain nombre de rapports sur des
réflexions sur les pas de demain donc
dans les vingt ans donc comment
s'oriente quelle stratégie
au regard de ces investissements est ma
dernière question concerne également le
domaine du numérique de la modernisation
600 millions d'euros était annoncée pour
ce volet là donc qu'elle sera quand ça
sera distribué quels seront les critères
d'attribution et voilà qu'elle est
qu'elle est là la stratégie parce que au
regard de cette somme là à la fois je
pense qu'on peut faire des choses
performante et le risque cependant de ça
c'est le saupoudrage donc je voudrais
avoir votre vision premier à briser demi
gros lot il ya des sens - jette
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
dès l'automne 2020 donc j'ai été informé
par plusieurs responsables
d'établissements de secteur privé non
lucratif de haute garonne de démission
d'agents attiré par l'hôpital et les
ehpad publics
la raison principale de la fuite de ses
compétences réside dans les distorsions
d'ailleurs de salaire au dépend donc des
soignants du secteur médico social
les mesures annoncées le 29 mai par le
gouvernement sont dans le bon sens près
de 73 mille salariés du secteur privé à
but non lucrative pourront bénéficier
d'une hausse de salaire
283 euros net par mois ces soignants et
ses accompagnants ont tenu bon durant
tout de la crise sanitaire
alors pourquoi attendre le 1er janvier
2022 pour l'inversé cette augmentation
salariale tant attendue alors que
d'autres la touche déjà depuis plusieurs
mois ma deuxième question
ce sont des infirmiers et infirmières
libéraux qui sont venus me voir et il
s'inquiète des menaces ce que pèse qui
pèsent sur leur métier
après la décision du haut conseil des
professions paramédicales d'accorder
plus d'autonomie aux aides soignants il
estime que la réalisation de ces de
certains actes sans en référer à un
infirmier sera préjudiciable aux
soignants ainsi qu'aux patients dont la
la sécurité risque d'être des trains
puis c'est pour cela qu'elle est votre
position et celle du gouvernement sur
l'articulation à définir entre
infirmiers et aides soignants notamment
dans le maintien des personnes âgées à
domicile et dans la prise en charge de
la dépendance en conservant donc le
meilleur environnement sanitaire puis
une troisième question alors que nous
abordons la quatrième étape du
déconfinement le 30 juin et que les
discothèques commente ouvrir le 9
juillet je ne peux 4 inquiète quand je
vois l'évolution de la situation en
israël qui fait figure donc qui faisait
figure de modèle quand autour de
vaccination de la population et à
l'immunité collective 40% des nouvelles
personnes contaminées sont vaccinés le
variant delta donc était extrêmement
contagieux est responsable de ces
contaminations
vous vous déplacez demain d'ailleurs
dans les landes où
amener la france où en est-on en france
sur la propagation de ce baril en delta
n'allons nous pas trop vite dans le
relâchement des gestes barrières le port
du masque dans les lieux clos et dans
les transports
sera-t-il bien maintenant sera-t-il bien
maintenu et quelle stratégie de
vaccination
avec cette nouvelle donne le
gouvernement a élaboré il lavaur utile
merci laurence cohen
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre donc à mon tour de vous poser
plusieurs questions tout d'abord sur
l'accès aux soins en santé mentale
j'ai été interpellées notamment par les
psychologues hospitalier concernant les
revalorisations salariales qui ont été
prévus donc dans l'accord ségur de la
santé la revalorisation des grilles
indiciaires et la prime d'engagement
collectif devait aboutir et d'ailleurs
vous l'avez confirmé à l'assemblée
nationale si je ne me trompe pas à une
augmentation de la rémunération des
psychologues à l'hôpital de l'ordre de
500 à 600 euros en fin de carrière mais
d'après les psychologues hospitalier qui
m'ont contacté
il n'y aurait pas à ce jour de
négociations qui ont été ouvertes sur
ses grilles donc ça pose problème
donc ma question c'est est-ce que
finalement les psychologues à l'hôpital
vont en bénéficier
et est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
l'ouverture prochaine de négociations
avec les psychologues hospitalier pour
justement revaloriser les grilles il
écrit indiciaire ça c'était ma première
question sur la profil et prophéties la
profession des infirmiers anesthésistes
voilà monsieur le ministre je suis
précise je ne vais pas
développer des des éléments que vous
connaissez par rapport aux politiques
parfois que vous portez mais sur la
profession des infirmiers anesthésistes
j'ai été également interpellés avec ma
collègue katia pourceaux poli par donc
par eux puisque vous les avez reçue je
crois pareillement le 27 mai dernier et
lors de cette et 2,7 et chance vous avez
affirmé la nécessité de faire évoluer
les professions du monde de la santé en
indiquant que les infirmiers
anesthésistes n'était pas éligible au
statut de pratiques avancées
donc je voudrais savoir finalement les
protocoles de coopération et la
validation d'acquis d'expérience ne
répondent pas aux revendications des
infirmiers anesthésistes qui eux
demandent une véritable évolution
statutaire donc que répondez vous
monsieur le ministre
finalement assez infirmiers
anesthésistes qui demande une
perspective de reconnaissance de leur de
leur métier je voudrais également vous
interroger par rapport aux praticiens
hospitaliers
nous avions reçu en audition avec la
présidente madame catherine de roche
donc ces praticiens hospitaliers le
segura supprimer les trois premières les
trois premiers échelons en débat qu'en
début pardon de carrière et a créé trois
échelons supplémentaires en fin de
carrière et la suppression en début de
carrière est positive pour les jeunes
médecins mais pénalise pénalisant
finalement pour les médecins plus
expérimentés qui perdent des années
d'ancienneté et il avait été extrêmement
précis nous ont donné des documents que
je peux tenir à votre disposition comme
je pense d'ailleurs la présidente de
notre commission et ils nous ont alertés
sur le fait que des médecins
hospitaliers quittait l'hôpital sur la
pointe des pieds ce qu'aucun de nous ne
souhaitent donc j'aimerais avoir des
explications et ma toute dernière
question est plus axé sur ce qui est en
train de se passer à l'ap-hp je sais que
vous êtes donc très sensible
bhl à la formation des personnels et
j'ai été extrêmement étonné d'ailleurs
je vous allez recevoir un courrier de ma
part mais si je préfère vous dire un peu
les choses
en fait on a attiré mon attention sur le
manque de financement de la prise en
charge de formations des aides
soignantes les puériculteurs et
puéricultrices dans le cadre de la
promotion interne au sein de
l'assistance publique des hôpitaux de
paris
et c'est très préjudiciable parce que
sur 350 lauréate cette année 120 se sont
vu recaler malgré le résultat
qualifiant faute de feuilles de
financement d'après monsieur hirsch
donc on ne peut pas alors qu'on manque
de personnel on ne peut pas laisser les
choses en état qu'elles sont finalement
les moyens que vous pouvez débloquer à
ce sujet pour permettre à ses personnels
de se former et de passer donc de
devenir éventuellement infirmier ou
infirmière je vous remercie par avance
et beaucoup de questions 15h à cerner
les causes ciblées et me faire l'effort
de ne pas être trop de ne pas faire de
trop longs tunnels pour sénateurs savary
l'espace numérique en santé
généralisation 1er janvier 2022 en
juillet d'ici fin juillet
expérimentation lancée dans trois
départements la haute garonne la somme
et la loire-atlantique et nous démarrons
également dans l'intervalle une campagne
d'information grand public et ça
marchera
et on attend ça avec beaucoup
d'impatience et la france va passer de
l'un des pays de queue de peloton en
l'espace de trois ans un des pays
leaders en matière numérique en sorte et
je dis ça je suis arrivé les choses
étaient lancés on a une formidable
direction du numérique en santé donc je
n'en ai je n'en prends pas directement
ou indirectement le bénéfice je dis
juste que le trust qui a été lancée en
matière de numérique en sortent et va
nous permettre de faire un bond en avant
monumentale sur les réanimateurs et les
formations j'étais à leur congrès la
semaine dernière où il ya deux semaines
encore une fois pardon pour les dates il
ya l'émir et les mares les intensiviste
réanimateurs les
anesthésistes-réanimateurs
heures ils souhaitent les uns et les
autres à voir une augmentation du nombre
d'internautes en formation je suis de
leur a dit cela étant cette année il y
as je crois quelques jeux pas dire de
bêtises mais quelques 260 postes de plus
d'un terne à pourvoir dont la moitié est
par la loi tourné vers les médecins
généralistes ce qui vous dit une
augmentation de 130 postes qui reste à
répartir dans les différentes
spécialités avec un certain nombre
d'engagements sur du pluri annuels qui
avaient été pris je pense à la
psychiatrie et la pédiatre d'autres je
peux pas dire à nouveau de bêtises
pardon si je ma langue fourche mais ça y
compris le concept
j'ai dit qu'il y aurait donc une
augmentation du nombre d'un terne formés
pour l'émigré démarre cette année qu'il
y aurait une augmentation plus sensible
l'année prochaine parce qu'il y aura
plus + 400 postes à répartir qui
permettra d'y aller et l'année d'après
encore plus de postes et donc je leur ai
dit que sur trois ans on allait
augmenter de façon très sensible le
nombre de réanimateurs et d'un
anesthésiste réanimateur en formation ça
peut pas se faire d'un seul coup comme
ça mais nous allons faire sur trois ans
avec tous les effectifs que nous pouvons
leur attribuer évidemment c'est ma
volonté vaccination des soignants
oui je les dis parce que j'ai été
interrogé sur la vie sur cette question
là je considère qu'il n'est pas normal
et c'est pas un problème franco français
l'italie l'allemagne l'angleterre tous
les pays qui nous entourent rencontre le
même problème on a un taux de couverture
de vaccination chez les soignants qui
est parfois plus faible que dans la
population générale c'est notamment le
cas on est pas on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas j'ai des soignants n'est pas de se
vacciner depuis le mois de janvier
nous mettons en oeuvre toutes les
campagnes de communication de
mobilisation je constate qu'il ya des
ehpad dans lesquels 10 % du personnel
est vacciné et d'autres dans lesquels
90% du personnel vacciner donc il n'y a
pas un problème national mais peut-être
un problème établissement par
établissement
je souhaite donc au cours de l'été nous
fassions fortement grandir la couverture
vaccinale de nos soignants ce en quoi je
le redis vraisemblablement en septembre
je pourrais être amené à proposer une
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants qui ne serait pas je ne peux
pas être un ministre de la santé qui
pourrait regarder dans l'hypothèse d'une
vague
j'espère qu'elle n'aura pas mais s'il
devait y en avoir une en octobre ou en
novembre
les ehpad se refermer parce que le virus
il rentrerait parce que les soignants
n'aurais pas fait ce geste éthique qui
consiste à se vacciner
je suis médecin quand je suis arrivé à
l'hôpital public pour mettre la blouse
j'ai dû attester du fait que j'ai été
vaccinés contre l'hépatite b entre
autres entre autres maladies donc ce
n'est pas une nouveauté
et je le dis on va travailler sur la
confiance sur l'accompagnement des
soignants qui doute mais je ne laisserai
pas je ne laisserai pas les ehpad à
nouveaux infectés par le virus c'est
c'est encore moins acceptable lorsque
c'est bien involontairement bien sûr
mais de fait par les soignants il ya un
ehpad dans les landes je crois ou six
soignants sont affectés aux variants
delta dont 5 non vaccinés et alors que
la plupart des résidents de l'ehpad sont
vaccinés 23 ont attrapé le virus
23 ils étaient vaccinés mais comme ils
sont très fragiles 95 ans boîte vaccinez
vous avez un risque plus important de
tomber malade et il ya trois
hospitalisations
je ne sais pas possible
sur les étudiants doute soudan sur vous
confirme qu'il ya pas besoin de décret
par contre je vous couvrir que son
décret nous l'avons commencée et
amplifier il ya 200 internes qui sont en
poste actuellement dans les zones sous
denses selon le mécanisme que le sénat
effectivement apportées à la loi aux tss
pour le sénateur mouillé sur le cd ségur
du médico-social j'ai envie de toi mon
ami cole hawes a presque répondu dans la
question qu'il a posée mais sur le
périmètre
oui le cti fédérer 183 euros net par
mois concerne le personnel soignant des
structures rattachées à la fonction
publique hospitalière et aux structures
médico-sociales nexen croix rouge fait
ap
il y aura la suite d'un périmètre pour
les structures sociales qui renvoyait
donc je parle d' allah de la zone je
parle de la famille à une conférence
sociale qui aura lieu avant la fin de
l'année dans la continuité des travaux
de michel laforcade et les 600 millions
d'euros du numérique dans les ehpad sont
elles vont servir à la fois du soft et
du hard c'est à dire équipements
tablette équipements réseau équipements
en application qui vont permettre
vous imaginez il ya est à peu près 600
millions de il ya peu près 600 mille
résidents en ehpad 600 millions d'euros
d'investissement c'est presque 1000
euros par résidents en ehpad
donc on peut faire beaucoup de choses il
y avait urgence pour la sénatrice
micouleau la fuite des soignants d'un
secteur à l'autre j'en entends parler
tous les jours et quand c'est un privé
que je vois et me disent que tous les
soignants quitte le privé par exemple
public
quand je vois le public qui me disent
que les soignants quitte le public pour
aller dans le privé
et quand je vois le médico-social me
disent qu'ils vont à l'hôpital et
l'hôpital qui vont dans le médico social
si je devais résumer à grands traits je
n'ai pas à ce stade de chiffres
attestant d'une quelconque fuite de
soignants en revanche et des mobilités
de soignants et de façon plus générale
je regarde le nombre de futurs soignants
c'est à dire le nombre de aspirants
infirmiers aides soignants qui
s'inscrivent dans l'information il
augmente et je vois le nombre de départs
de l'ensemble des secteurs qui depuis le
ségur s'est réduit les ce malgré
l'impact de la crise donc on regardera
ça mais faisons attention
et voilà je ne crois pas du tout à des
alliés de la fuite ou alors ils font ça
fuite partout mais
mais ce que je veux dire pourquoi le 1er
janvier 2022 celle accord syndical qui a
été signé vers le temps de mettre en
place les modalités de paiement le temps
de mettre en place tout cela les
syndicats se sont engagés sur cette date
du 1er janvier 2022 pour appliquer
l'accord dans le secteur médico-social
vous poser une question qui est pour moi
un peu emblématique de ce que je disais
tout à l'heure je ne le ferais pas mais
prenez pas du tout pour vous mais sur le
retard pris par notre pays dans un
certain nombre de domaines
quand vous dites qu'ils aient des
infirmiers ou infirmières libérales qui
se sentent menacés par une augmentation
de l'autonomie t7 soignants notre
système de santé est un système
merveilleux où tout le monde est très
impliqué mais où tout le monde se sent
menacé par les personnes avec qui y
travaillent
et à force de se sentir menacé on a eu
autant
pardonnez moi mais de deux de blocage
avec des difficultés à adapter la loi
et d'ailleurs même quand on a posé
plusieurs questions qui relèvent
exactement de cette dynamique là avec
des gens qui se sentent qu'ils veulent
se catégoriser à part des autres
tout le monde me sentir spéciale de par
rapport aux autres c'est pas une
difficulté pour moi mais on doit pas
empêcher notre système d'évoluer pour
tenir compte de l'évolution des
compétences des métiers des missions de
chacun donc non il n'y a aucune remise
en question du rôle des infirmiers
libéraux dans le système de santé
de la même manière que je dis aux
médecins que non le sait pas parce qu'il
y aura des hypers médecine de ville que
la médecine libérale va mourir et c'est
pas de la même manière jeudi au aux
aides soignants que c'est pas parce
qu'on a des assistants de gérontologie
qui se développe que sa valeur leur
prendre leur mission et leur métier
voyez ce que je veux dire
à chaque fois tout le monde se quitte
bons amis en disant mais chacun veut que
le système évolue mais en fait il veut
pas il veut pas que l'évolution se fasse
trop à son détriment aussi au détriment
de personnes
en fait on permet davantage aux gens de
coopérer de travailler ensemble et
d'avoir un peu plus d'autonomie dans ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire
voilà c'est ma logique et je n'en
démordrai pas parce que nos pays a pris
trente ans de retard savez on a perdu
dix ans à savoir si on avait parlé de
transfert de compétences ou de
délégations de tâches puis ensuite on a
parlé de pratiques avancées de
coopération etc
même les mots sont des crises en santé
mais je dis juste que à travers de la
crise sanitaire on a vu qu'en réalité
quand on faisait moins attention à ce
qu'ils redoutaient qu'à ceux qui se
mobilisent sur le terrain eh bien on
arrivait à
bouger notre système de santé et je vous
promets que je ne menace aucunement
aucune profession dans son intégrité sa
capacité à soigner les gens mais que je
veux permettre à chacun et à chacune de
déployer ses compétences qui sont
souvent sous utilisé au service des
malades vous avez posé des questions sur
la vaccination c'est pas le lieu mais je
vais comme vous réponds non
de ce que j'ai vu en israël il ya très
peu d'impact sanitaire lié à des
contaminations aux variants delta ce
qu'on sait c'est que la vaccination
protège à plus de 80 % vis-à-vis du
variante lta et c'est plus de 90% nous
voir 94%
lorsqu'il y a un risque
d'hospitalisation donc en fait le vaccin
même si vous pouvez tomber malade entre
guillemets ou est porteur du virus dans
un certain nombre de situations
eh bien vous évite les formes graves et
les hospitalisations et au fond c'est ça
qu'on souhaite le plus ardemment éviter
aux gens de tomber gravement malade de
mourir ou de ou de conserver des
séquelles et la logique
madame la sénatrice et de rouvrir notre
pays mais ne pas abandonner les gestes
barrières et de ne pas oublier que le
virus peut être là et vous avez raison
de souligner que je serai demain dans
les landes avec le premier ministre
puisque au maniement d'un état des lieux
d'une variante delta dans notre pays le
variant delta représente pas loin de 10%
des nouvelles contaminations dans notre
pays on est au même niveau que
l'allemagne au mérite au même niveau que
les états unis l'om est le dit très bien
et très aisément le variant delta et le
variant qui va prendre le leadership sur
toutes les tours toutes les autres
formes de virus coville 19 parce qu'il
est 60% plus contagieux 60% plus
contagieux il n'ya pas d'échappement
vaccinale plus important qu'avec les
autres variantes donc il faut se faire
vacciner c'est fondamental c'est le seul
moyen toutes façons d'y arriver et ce
variant delta on le retrouve à 12 % en
ile-de-france et puis on retrouve des
classes terre dans des situations
qu'aujourd'hui on est capable de tracer
avec une précision redoutable
je peux vous dire qu'à strasbourg il ya
eu un examen oral dans une école d'art
avec des étudiants et des enseignants où
il y avait manifestement pas le respect
des gestes-barrières est pas le port de
masques il est plusieurs contaminations
un étudiant contaminée est ensuite allé
faire la bringue pour fêter la fin des
épreuves
il ya eu des contaminations autour de
lui on a identifié 50 cas contact ce qui
n'est pas rien et donc c'est ainsi que
par les choses aujourd'hui on est
capable quand je vous disais d'avoir une
traçabilité très très fine quartier par
quartier ce qui nous permet de faire un
contact racing opérationnelles y compris
ce qu'on appelle le rétrospective c'est
à dire le tracking à la japonaise si on
s'arrête pas aux personnes que la
personne malade a pu contaminer on va
chercher aussi les personnes que la
personne malade qui aurait pu contaminer
la personne malade et on remonte les
chaînes de contamination comme ça
néanmoins quand vous avez un invariant
contagieux et qui trouve encore des gens
a contaminé parce que les gens ne sont
pas encore vaccinés eh bien oui il ya
des départs épidémique potentiel dans
les landes
nous y allons parce que c'est 70% des
souches virales en circulation qui
correspondent désormais aux variants
delta est que pour la première fois et
c'est le seul département
on assiste à une augmentation du taux
d'incidence de 10% sur une semaine et
donc il dépasse les 50 il n'y a pas de
drame
il n'y a pas d'impact sanitaire sa
touche essentiellement des jeunes de
moins de 50 ans enfin on est payé pour
savoir
on a payé pour savoir que quand ça
commence à toucher les jeunes amants
donner sa touche et moins jeunes et
qu'il ya alors un impact sanitaire la
réponse madame la sénatrice vaccination
vaccination nous avons réalisé hier
90000 primo injection de moins que ce
que nous étions capables de réaliser
je le dis aux français la campagne
vaccinale n'est pas terminé nous avons
nous sommes pas face à une situation
inhabituelle ou exceptionnelles partout
autour de nous états unis israël compris
on a cette forme cette forme d' à 70 qui
arrive quand on dépasse les 60% de
vaccination des adultes
il faut remonter cette couverture
vaccinale nous avons les vaccins au mois
de juin
une personne qui se fait vacciner
aujourd'hui peut avoir son rappel dans
trois semaines et peut avoir sont pas
salutaire pour les vacances à la mi
juillet donc oui la fin juillet c'est
vraiment fondamental d'entendre
d'entendre ce message et notamment à
destination des patients des personnes
jeunes parce que ils sont ils font
circuler le virus il peut le faire
circuler et après il ya d'autres
clusters de variants delta je le disais
dans le bas rhin tout à l'heure en
citant strasbourg et d'autres endroits
localisés mais dans les landes on
on commence à voir un début de diffusion
communautaire et donc on ne peut
évidemment pas qu'il y ait une reprise
épidémique
on sait faire la sénatrice qu'il ya un
an j'étais en mayenne
et c'est en mayenne que ça repartait et
on a interrompu l'épidémie en mayenne on
va faire le maximum pour l'interrompre
aussi dans les landes il ya 2000 cas par
jour de virus en france c'est beaucoup
moins c'est 20 fois moins qu'il ya
quelques semaines voire 30 fois moins
nous serons à 1000 cas dans une semaine
ou descendre en dessous des 1000 cas
donc nous serons de plus en plus
efficaces mais tant que la guerre n'est
pas finie il faut pas se désarmer pour
les sénatrices cohen je vous disais il
ya eu quelques quelques réflexions
question que j'ai posée que je connais
bien parce que c'est celle de ces deux
syndicats et vous en faites vous en
faites ici il est conscient et
psychologues les psychologues touche
bien les cti à l'hôpital donc elles ont
touché les 183 euros net de plus par
mois pourront percevoir également la
prime d'engagement collectif c'est le
pas mieux piller 3d revalorisation du
ségur
il ya un milliard d'euros qui est
dessinée qui peut permettre aux
soignants de toucher jusqu'à 100 euros
net par mois de plus quand ils sont
engagées dans des programmes dits
d'engagement collectif et je vous
confirme que les revalorisations de
grille des catégories soignante concerne
les soignants les médico techniques et
les personnels de rééducation dont ne
font pas partie
les psychologues dans le secteur
hospitalier néanmoins il ya des assises
de la santé mentale et de la psychiatrie
qui se tiendront en septembre
je vous permet d'implémenter encore et
d'améliorer encore et de renforcer
encore la place des psychologues du
système de santé
nous verrons à ce moment-là ce qu'il en
ressort sur les hyades j'ai reçu j'ai
fait plus que recevoir les ja j'ai reçu
les syndicats et ensuite j'ai reçu les
syndicats dans une vision conférence où
chaque iyad étaient invités à participer
sur 12000 i had que compte notre pays
j'ai réuni 4500 connexion d'illiad donc
sans doute plus de 5 6 milles yade
présent et j'avais un côté très sensible
notamment la cgt avec qui nous avons
débattu à bâtons rompus pendant une
heure et je crois avoir quand nous avons
pu lever un certain nombre
d'incompréhensions les ziad cherchent
leur place dans le système de santé
qu'elle y z'ont en propre avec non
seulement la reconnaissance d'une
spécialité infirmière avec les
bonifications qui vont avec
et notamment la nba qui est une prime
qui majore encore la rémunération d
iliad mais en plus les ja ne sont pas du
tout des classes et ou dégradée par
rapport à dissiper à et on a expliqué on
a débattu des missions qui sont
différentes la mission vous avez voté
d'un hyper c'est travailler en totale
autonomie
par exemple dans un service de
cancérologie de faire les premières
consultations etc
c'est pas la même chose ce n'est ni
moins bien ni mieux que le statut
d'infirmiers spécialisés c'est
totalement différent et il ya une
mission à l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales qui est en cours sur
la filière de réanimation qui permettra
d'aborder ensuite sereinement avec les
représentants des dyades comment faire
évoluer davantage leur profession je
suis très sensible quand ils me disent
que ils sont parfois seul à bord pendant
l'opération d'un malade une fois que le
des saisies staff la sédation etc en
salle de réveil ne peuvent pas prescrire
du paracétamol donc c'est plutôt dans ce
sens là qu'il faut qu'on fasse évoluer
les choses
quant aux rémunérations des i had un
lien en fin de carrière peut toucher
plus qu un anesthésiste en début de
carrière ce qu'on a dit ce qu'on a
discuté ensemble grâce aux ségur avec
pour le coup des revalorisations qui
sont qui sont qui sont importantes sur
les grilles de médical là pardon c'est à
la fois d'incompréhension et à la fois
de la volonté manifeste de transmettre
une mauvaise information initialement
par certains non signataires du ségur
personnes
aucun médecin de l'hôpital public n'a
perdu en ancienneté en salaire ou en
retraite
vous avez ce qui se passe dans toute
réforme des grilles et des statues dans
la fonction publique qu'elle soit
hospitalière d'état ou territoriale
quand vous signez un accord ça me
concerne les flux entrants ce qu'on
appelait flux et parce qu'on appelle le
mot est moche mais c'est comme ça dans
la loi ce qu'on appelle les stocks de
personnel et donc vous avez création de
deux grilles parallèle ce qui rentre
poste ségur et ceux qui étaient déjà
dans la carrière et donc certains ont
cru ou ont compris on redoutait de
perdre trois échelons quand en réalité
ils gardent leur resto mais évoluent sur
une grille parallèle qui est différente
personne n'a perdu d'argent le segura
asada c'est fantastique c'est que
personne ne peut vous dire j'ai mûri
- après quand tout le monde gagne plus
un couple de un couple de médecins
praticiens hospitaliers qui perçoit qui
a mon âge et qui faria l'hôpital public
avec la revalorisation de l'irrespect
eux ils gagnent 10 ni l'euro à deux nets
de plus par an madame la sénatrice
je ne crois pas du tout que les médecins
démissionne à cause du ségur
je peux comprendre que ça ne répond pas
à toutes les attentes pardon parce que
je discutais avec un couple hier de
praticiens hospitaliers qui me disait
que ça avait finalement changé leur vie
parce que ils ont fait le calcul sur 25
ans à ses deux cent cinquante mille
euros qu'ils ont pu acheter une petite
résidence pas très loin de la mer et
c'est ce que changer de ségur mais si
vous préférez jeu peut fonctionner en ph
un ph qui touchait 6 ans il est à 1010
et donc ils tous 400 euros de plus par
mois donc je ne dis pas que c'est je
peux être que ça répond pas à toutes les
attentes
mais personne n'a été mon discours se
dire personne n'a perdu de l'argent à
personne les pénaliser ou rétrogradés
cause du ségur tout le monde est gagnant
et enfin la prise en charge insuffisant
de la formation certains aides soignants
dans les hôpitaux pour leur permettre de
devenir infirmier là je vous donne le
point
c'est à dire que oui il faut qu'on
finance davantage de formation
d'aides-soignants il n'est pas normal
qu'un et soignants qui décide de
s'engager dans une formation
professionnalisante pour pouvoir devenir
infirmier leur même qu'on manque
d'infirmiers ne soit ne puisse pas être
davantage accompagner une question de
budget et nous y travaillons très bien
d'autres questions moi j'avais un point
pas vous avez parlé
abrasive écolo de des gestes barrières
quand j'étais alertés par un médecin
généraliste la géorgienne qui alertait
sur le non-respect des chaises varié en
matière de lavage des mains et on le
voit quand on rend des magasins ou avant
les gens utilisaient le gel non il
utilise pratiquement plus avec une
recrudescence très nette des
gastroentérites abbas l'a donc je pense
que la campagne de sur les gestes
barrières mais en y incluant le lavage
des mains est quelque chose de majeur et
si on les grilles salariales moi j'ai
reçu une
on avait reçu le syndicat en effet mais
moi j'ai reçu le collectif dps à
l'horizon 2030
il ya quand même une incompréhension
parce qu'ils étaient sur les mêmes
réflexions et souhaitait ces deux
grilles ph nommé avantage non mais après
c'est dur vous confirmez bien qu'il ya
bien les deux cris qui fonctionnent en
parallèle détruit comme toutes les
formes et fonctions publiques concédées
aux formes avantageuses
c'est comme ça quand ces désavantages
c'est ainsi dans toutes les réformes et
d'ailleurs les syndicats l'ont compris
quand ils y ont signé l'accord et hyper
cette personne était clan traître mais
peut-être que dans l'accompagnement et
dans l'explication qu'a été donné
initialement dont sur la première
feuille de paye certains incendies ont
le sentiment qu'ils qui baisse c'est
qu'il en a vu des jeunes rentrés dans la
carrière dont trois quatre ans après eux
qui est au même échelon en fait les deux
grilles qui sont différentes et donc
c'est ce n'est pas antinomique qui fait
que tout le monde ait gagné mais c'est
sûr que si vous commencez votre carrière
après le ségur vous aurez sur votre
carrière plus de rémunération que si
vous aviez démarrer avant de ségur
encore une fois c'est très classique
dans les réformes de la fonction
publique 1 c'est même la règle on va
continuer corinne imbert pascal bruni
elle est jamais de nommer cheminée
iacovelli merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre j'ai revenir sur le
point évoqué par mon collègue rené paul
savary
et sur ce que le sénat a voté dans la
loi sur relative à l'organisation la
transformation du système de santé en
2019 j'ai l'impression qu'on se comprend
pas excusez moi vous avez répondu
d'ailleurs à rené paul savary cas et pas
besoin de décret dont il y en a besoin
d'un pour certaines spécialités si vous
le souhaitez parce qu'il ya des tensions
en médecine générale mais il ya aussi
des tensions dans certaines spécialités
et si vous voulez intégrer cette
obligation d'au moins six mois
pardon si si c'est dans la loi
mentionnant pas dans la version votée à
l'assemblée nationale la version
définitive un médiatrice a été retirée
l'obligation je pense qu'ici c'est
l'enfer de compréhension c'était pas
vraiment d'amis c'est bien de faire
voter la notion d'obligation de stage en
dessous dans sa a été supprimée au
profit d'une notion d' incitation en
zones sous denses étaient dans la
dernière mouture de l'hôtesse
il semble qu'en en commission mixte
paritaire où c'était un point dur pour
nous et qu'on ne veut rien lâcher alors
je sais bien que côté ministère personne
n'en voudrait côté l'assemblée nationale
personne n'en voulait côté étudiants en
médecine personne n'en voulait on est
bien d'accord mais ya quand même à une
réalité et vous voyez le temps passe
huit l'avantagent de la loi votée en
il faut savoir que il est normal qu'elle
ne pouvait s'imposer s'appliquer aux
internes en médecine avant ceux qui
rentraient qui sont rentrés en première
année d'internât de médecine générale au
1er novembre 2019
ça veut dire qu'ils vont rentrer en
troisième année au 1er novembre 2021
donc je ne doute pas de votre chiffre de
120 en interne en stage mais j'allais
dire ça c'est la maquette ancien
ancienne mouture
si la loi s'applique bien des
internautes dernière année médecine
générale me semble-t-il de mémoire il y
en à 3506 pendant au moins six mois ils
viennent au moins pendant six mois en
dans le même dans le même cabinet
médical dans la même maison santé en
autonomie superviser ans
en fort des médecins déjà installé
maître de stage vous permettre de staël
d'ailleurs ça a été une discussion qu'on
avait qu'on avait âprement évoqué c'est
35 étudiants en dernière année dans la
dernière ligne droite de leurs études en
médecine générale qui peuvent venir en
renfort de médecins déjà installé pas au
milieu ne part pas tout seul bien sûr
mais en renfort de messages je pense que
le sujet est important
et moi je voudrais savoir si oui ou non
la maquette va évoluer qu'elle va
s'appliquer au 1er novembre 2021 pour
que ses étudiants qui seront dernières
années d'internât messi général puisse
venir au moins six mois en renfort des
praticiens déjà installés
bien sûr dans les zones sous denses en
lien avec le zonage déterminé par les
agences régionales de santé je vous
remercie
pascale gruny merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre
moi je suis vous parler d'un sujet à
côté mais qui est quand même important
pour pour la santé nous sommes en train
d'étudier la proposition de loi sur la
santé au travail et nous ne nous
entendons pas sûr sur ce sujet or vous
parlez beaucoup de décloisonnement et
nous en fait c'est ce qu'on souhaite
aussi et notamment avec une meilleure
articulation du dossier médical
personnel et dossier médical en santé au
travail donc
en fait on voulait surtout vous entendre
en fait sur ce que vous pensiez en fait
de la santé au travail par rapport à
ceux des publics
merci les abbés doisneau oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre merci d'avoir donné un certain
nombre de précisions alors je vais pas
revenir sur les questions qui ont déjà
été posées simplement sur les mesures du
ségur
moi j'entends effectivement les efforts
qui ont été faits par le gouvernement
sur un certain nombre de rémunération
pour un certain nombre de professionnels
mais comment expliquez vous que nous
avons un défilé dans nos permanences et
que nous ayons des courriers des
courriels qui nous parviennent d'autres
professionnels qui ont vraiment un
sentiment d'injustice parce que ils ont
vraiment l'impression et bien qu'ils ne
sont pas considérés à la même hauteur de
valeur de leur engagement dans leur
profession alors moi j'ai bien entendu
qu'effectivement il y aura des paliers
enfin des paliers qu'il y ait des
avancées pour eux aussi alors pour le
médico social pour le social mais est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir un tableau avec les
professionnels concernés qui nous
parviennent
parce que en réalité moi j'ai
l'impression que les fédérations les
syndicats ne transmettent pas sur le
terrain à leur propre fédération les
éléments d'avancé avec votre ministère
parce que ça donne une confusion sur le
terrain monsieur le ministre qui est
intolérable parce que finalement les uns
et les autres on essaye d'apaiser de
dire que les choses avancent mais on n'a
pas vraiment les dates vous venez de
nous en donner quelques unes
vous venez nous donner aussi quelques
éléments de contexte sur le dialogue
social mais vraiment donné nous quelque
chose qui ressemble un tableau que l'on
puisse remettre à tous ceux qui viennent
nous rendre visite
par ailleurs je voudrais aussi vous dire
que sur la réanimation il y a
effectivement
le besoin de réanimateurs de médecins
réanimateurs mais il y a aussi besoin de
reconnaissance sur les infirmières parce
que là on voit bien qu'elle joue un rôle
primordial
et en fait elles n'ont pas de formation
sinon sur le terrain or une fois
qu'elles sont formés beaucoup tu
beaucoup repartent
il ya un turnover qui était évident donc
comment peut-on revoir le statut des
infirmières réanimatrice ou d'infirmier
réanimateurs pour permettre justement de
les garder dans les services un petit
mot aussi sur le statut des sages-femmes
parce que j'y suis très attaché elles
ont de plus en plus de prérogatives mais
est ce que vous avancez au ministère sur
justement un statut qui serait plus en
relation avec leurs responsabilités vous
dire aussi que sur le terrain on manque
d'infirmières
j'étais en réunion tout dernièrement
alors en mayenne avec le siad locales et
on a un manque d'infirmières pour les
astreintes et on a un manque
d'infirmières pour cet été pour tenir
tout simplement les besoins du terrain
pour couvrir simplement les besoins du
territoire et je vous assure que c'est
une véritable angoisse pour l'ensemble
des professionnels qui se demande bien
comment ils vont pouvoir réaliser
en tout cas les soins aux malades et
puis surtout on s'interroge sur l'avenir
quoi vraiment michel meunier et ensuite
avec michel merci à la présidence du
merci monsieur le ministre alors dans la
même région mais dans un autre
département
en loire atlantique et à propos de ce
qu'on appelle est ce qu'on a appris les
oubliés du ségur à chaque question pour
d'actualité au gouvernement il ya
évidemment une question là dessus c'est
pas clair
et donc là on va profiter de votre
présence pour avoir la clarté des
personnes qui sont ou pas concernés par
ces revalorisations je prendre qu'un
seul exemple en loire atlantique un
établissement public qui gère du
médico-social enfants et adultes je
parle de mindin et qui va avoir trois
catégories fin trois profils de salariés
différents selon qu'ils soient donc
infirmiers selon qu'ils soient
personnels soignants administratifs
psychologues éducateurs ash et cetera et
vous pensez bien que c'est pas clair du
tout puisque la mission est la même mais
le salaire ne sera pas équivalent à la à
la fin du mois donc là dessus est-ce que
vous avez des éléments de réponse à
donner sur ces personnels qui
appartiennent donc à une structure où
les choses ont pas été posée d'emblée
dans le cadre c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
que l'établissement soit partiellement
ou totalement financé par la cpam
apparemment pour pouvoir bénéficier des
revalorisations et salariales donc ça
c'est une première question
deuxième question vous l'avez déjà
entendu et répondu partiellement mais
j'insiste sur les psychologues à
l'hôpital vos engagements on les entend
on les prend mais apparemment ça ne va
pas jusqu'à la négociation et la
revalorisation des grilles salariales
donc qu'en est il exactement pour les
psychologues de l'hôpital
et puis une deuxième une dernière
question c'est sur l'essai pts donc
pendant la crise sanitaire il ya eu des
choses qui se sont débloquées et c'est
tant mieux
est ce que on peut espérer que les
ars auront pour mission de peut-être
structurer ce qui a été établi
formellement parfois sur les territoires
qui sont encore à la traîne
correspondant sur ces pts merci xavier
iacovelli oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mais ma question
concerne la télémédecine et son
déploiement dans dans les territoires
suite à la crise qu vide donc cette
pratique médicale à distance a été
particulièrement utile pendant
l'épidémie
que ce soit sur la téléconsultation la
téléexpertise ou la télésurveillance
médicale en mars 2020 d'ailleurs vous là
où vous l'aviez annonciez annoncé
l'assouplissement des conditions de
réalisation de la télémédecine pour
faire face à l'épidémie
il s'agit donc d'une pratique à la fois
innovante mais qui a aussi porté ses
fruits en aidant notamment les
professionnels de ville à prendre en
charge les patients et d'ailleurs les
français ont répondu favorablement et se
sont pleinement saisi de cet outil
puisque au cours de l'année 2020 on a eu
19 millions de télé consultation qui ont
été qui ont été facturés
plus largement il s'agit aussi d'un
outil est non négligeable pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux
on en parlait également en commission et
dans leur foi et favoriser l'accès de
tous nos concitoyens à des soins sur
l'ensemble du territoire selon une
enquête qui a été publiée en tout début
2020 68% des français se déclarent
favorables au développement de la
téléconsultation et 58% se disent prêts
à y recourir
alors j'ai deux questions pouvez vous
nous faire un point d'étape sur le
déploiement de la médecine et et de des
dates de la télémédecine pardon et les
résultats obtenus à l'aune de la crise
sanitaire est ma deuxième question sur
quelles pistes sont privilégiées pour
accélérer ce déploiement de la
télémédecine afin de répondre aux défis
de notre système de santé et favoriser
un égal accès à tous nos concitoyens sur
le territoire monsieur le ministre
alors pour la sénatrice madame semry
timbert j'ai la rédaction précise si
vous le souhaitez du texte tel qu'il a
été adopté
je vais vous le trouvez hollande nous y
voilà je cite le déploiement tout au
long des études de médecine d'une offre
de stage dans les zones caractérisées
par une offre de soins insuffisante ou
des difficultés dans l'accès aux soins
défini en application des articles l
14 34 erika du code de santé publique
fait l'objet d'une évaluation tous les
trois ans par les ministres chargés de
la santé de l'enseignement supérieur
cette évolution est transmise au
parlement et sur la rédaction en réalité
sur ce qui restait à l'issue du la fin
du texte
l'inter en médecine générale effectué un
stage préférentiellement en zones sous
denses dans sa dernière année d'internât
si on n'est pas d'accord le contenu de
la loi bg oui m'autorise je vous parle
de l'article 2 l'article 2 de cette loi
monsieur le ministre
où il est dit alors attendez il faut que
je les étudiants de médecine générale
réalise au cours de la dernière année du
troisième cycle de médecine au minimum
un stage d'un semestre en pratique
ambulatoires sous le régime d'autonomie
supervise enfin je les raccourcis là
mais c'est ça aux deux le deuxièmement
de l'article 2 de la loi je pense qu'on
ne parle pas de la même chose c'est bien
pour ça que je suis revenu sur sur les
fonts ça le fasse en ambulatoire matrix
[Musique]
il ya le stage en ambulatoire fait
partie de la maquette des internes qui
est obligatoire et le stage de obligat
l'obligatoire zones sous denses qui a
été retirée de la loi avec l'engagement
dans l'agenda rural développer à terme
400 places pour des internes en
ambulatoire enfin d'internât en zones
rurales et zones sous denses nous nous
en sommes déjà à 200 nous travaillons
sur la maîtrise de stage pour pouvoir
déployer d'autres terrains de stage pour
monter à 400 écoutez moi je vous parle
de l'article 2 de la loi
oui voilà et je crois qu'on ne peut pas
où on après vous me lisez que je jeûne
ou pas ce que vous lisez
c'est bien la loi mais on n'est pas au
même endroit on parle pas de la même
chose et moi je vous parle vraiment d'un
stage en autonomie superviser d'au moins
six mois qui a fait débat je vous le
promets je connaisse je connais les
oppositions à la fois de la ministre de
l'assemblée national des internes mais
c'était justement le point concret très
pragmatique d'une disposition mise dans
la loi qui pouvait avoir une application
à court terme puisque deux ans après ça
peut être mis en place et elle
s'applique à 3500 internes en médecine
générale
donc moi je suis à votre disposition
pour qu'on en reparle mais je vous
promets que c'était ça le sujet redon oc
pardonnez moi je travaille avec des
administrations qui sont beaucoup plus
compétentes que moi et qui travaillent
dessus au quotidien permanent
on reprend les choses vous avez les
internes de médecine générale peuvent
réaliser un semestre en ambulatoire à la
fin de leur maquette ça c'est fait et
c'est la règle ça c'est fait et c'est la
règle ensuite il a encouragé les
internes des spécialités d'organes a
réalisé des stages en milieu ambulatoire
vers la fin de la maquette et ça nous y
travaillons au développement des
maîtrises de stage qui n'existe pas
encore aujourd'hui et la notion
d'obligation quelle qu'elle soit dans
les dents que ce soit pour avoir des
stages en ambulatoire des stages en
dessous de danse n'a pas été retenu dans
les critères de la loi
alors moi c'est un
un truc il dit enfin un article qui dit
jeu les étudiants en médecine générale
réalise au cours de la dernière année du
troisième cycle de médecine au minimum
un stage d'un semestre
en pratique ambulatoire ce stage est
réalisé dans les lieux à gré en priorité
dans les zones mentionnées au 1er de
l'article du code de santé publique il
effectué sous un régime d'autorisation
d'autonomie superviser et cette pratique
ambulatoire peut être étendue par décret
à d'autres spécialités exercice
majoritairement vu la toile à un moment
contre la région 17 août que les
internes de météores est derrière toi
les hauteurs de métal doré dernières
années font un stage en ambulatoire avec
un maître de stage qu'on appelle
autonomie superviser c'est pas ça mais
j'étais la loi vous savez quoi on va
faire une réunion avec la dg os avec des
gens avec des doyens si vous voulez mais
tous les acteurs vous leur direz que
c'est pas ça puis vous en discuter avec
eux et moi je serai là mais on veut te
pète pas passé il aurait su que vous dis
qu'on n'a pas la même lecture de la loi
donc on n'a pas la même lecture de la
loi ça arrive mais obliger toutes les
administrations et les universités avec
lesquels on travaille pour le déployer
qui ont la même lecture de la loi que
moi donc si vous voulez on en fera un
point en poche jean hamon va vérifier ça
pas passer on va pas passer le long
discours là dessus mais il ya quand même
à une incompréhension totale entre ce
que nous on a pu voter est ce qui est
invisible non ou alors on s'est fait
avoir sur la rédaction continue pour
madame
pour madame la sénatrice uni c'est la
moitié du travail relève du portefeuille
de laurent petit rashevski qui est
aujourd'hui avec elisabeth borg pour ça
qu'on m'entende et moins sur la question
de la médecine du travail
néanmoins néanmoins je m'intéresse
évidemment ces questions et j'aurai
beaucoup de chose à en dire vous
imaginez bien
actuellement je peux vous dire qu'on
travaille sur les modalités d'accès à la
médecine du travail au dmp
c'était l'objet de la question est posée
il travaille que la direction numérique
en santé le direction des affaires
juridiques s'est pas un sujet qui est
simple croyez-moi on travaille dessus et
d'ici l'examen du texte on aura des
réponses évidemment vous apporter pour
la sénatrice doisneau le attendait ce
que du coup le oui et bien le tableau
s'était c'était c'est oui le tableau le
tableau de tableaux faire le dessin d'un
oiseau l'esprit du ségur l'esprit du
ségur de la santé initial c'était en
sortie de crise président de pouvoir
répondre à des revendications salariales
de soignant à l'hôpital et où vous
souvenez quand même revendication qui
portait sur 300 euros au cours du ségur
il a été arrêté dans un accord envoie
une fois majoritaire que au delà même
des soignants et des infirmières des
aides soignantes tout le monde touchera
une revalorisation y compris le
cantinier y compris le personnel
administratif etc
un million et demi de personnes ce qui
fait que leur boulot pas grossi apporte
de façon importante et les 300 euros en
fait ils ont été déclinés avec 183 euros
nets de cti pour tout le monde
100 euros d'engagement collectif c'est
100 euros net par mois pour ceux qui le
percevront mais ce sera une partie non
négligeable
et puis les revalorisations de vie
salariale qui fait qu'en fin de compte
on n'est pas à trois cents euros sur
certaines spécialités sur même sur des
métiers infirmiers en fin de carrière on
a des plus 500 +550 voire plus 600 euros
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs j'entends parfois
des revendications des syndicats non
signataires
qui vous a demandé 300 g bien oui mais
regardez potentiellement c'est plus six
ans oui mais c'est parce qu'on a demandé
donc j'écoute et on mettra jamais tout
le monde d'accord ce qui est sûr c'est
que le périmètre a été élargi de façon
importante
et évidemment il ya ce qu'on appelle
l'effet reconventionnelle et vous avez
des gens qui ont dit mais moi je fais le
même métier mais dans un autre secteur
affecté à l'hôpital public et je ne
touche pas la revalorisation
acte 1 du ségur deux actes à la mission
laforcade on les a inclus et ensuite
vous avez des gens dans le milieu
associatif c'est à dire dans le milieu
privé non lucratif pense à la
croix-rouge pinceau au samu social qui
ont dit mais nous on a un métier de
soins alors oui on n'est pas l'hôpital
mais on a un métier de soins et on les
perçoit pas acte 2 de la mission
laforcade on les inclut encore cent
mille personnes supplémentaires donc on
n'est pas loin des deux millions de
bénéficiaires du ségur
mais là vous avez un effet
reconventionnelle ensuite par cascades
vous avez aujourd'hui et je m'entends
parfaitement je peux être en train de
critiquer c'est juste que vous avez
maintenant des acteurs du social sont
pas dans le soin guillemets qui sont en
social auprès de personnes en situation
de handicap ou dans des situations
particulières qu'ils disent mais
finalement moi aussi je j'aspire la même
chose je vous dis juste que on ne parle
plus du tout enfin 2021 de ce dont on
parle est allaité 2020 on n'est plus
dans le sigle de la santé pour
revaloriser les infirmiers à l'hôpital
on a on est allé dans un périmètre
beaucoup plus large qui peut
potentiellement englober si vous prenez
tout le tous les salariés tout le
secteur social médico-social et ce qui
est salutaire du public privé vous allez
arriver à 4 millions 5 millions et c est
derrière vous aurez un effet
reconventionnelle avec des gens qui vont
dire mais moi je travaille au contact
des enfants sans être dans le soin et
c'est là donc je comprends parfaitement
ses revendications je dis juste que on
ne peut pas taxer le ségur d'avoir
laissé de côté des gens alors qu'il a
englobé beaucoup plus de personnes que
ce qui était prévu initialement
et pour tout cela encore une fois et à
chaque étape on a un accord majoritaire
syndical force ouvrière unsa cfdt jeudi
parce que c'est pas tout le temps qu'on
ait des accords majoritaires avec des
syndicats or c'est le cas donc signe que
les choses se passent bien
j'entends que vous voulez un tableau je
suis tout à fait favorable à ce qu'on
vous donne un tableau le tableau sera
long parce que même moi j'ai des
tableaux mes collègues quand on ajoute
tous les accords ça fait beaucoup de
monde mais on vous donnera un tableau
contact sur les infirmières de
réanimation pareil au congrès de
des animateurs on en a parlé il ya 2000
infirmiers spécialisés de réa
aujourd'hui c'est à dire environ 1 pour
2,5 me l'idée c'est de faire évoluer
pour qu'il y en ait davantage avec un
meilleur taux d'encadrement mais ça fait
partie aussi la mission igas qui doit me
rende ses conclusions pour qu'on puisse
développer davantage de professionnels
spécialisés on l'a vue puis par ailleurs
depuis le début de la crise ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de soignants non
spécialisés qui se sont formés sur le
tas en pratiquant simulation en moquant
numérique en réalité pour prêter main
forte à leurs collègues en en réa et ça
a été extrêmement utiles sur les
sages-femmes ça aussi ça cham je vais
recevoir pareil je faire une visio avec
seront invités tous et sa chambre de ce
pays pour qu'on puisse discuter une
heure à bâtons rompus questions réponses
j'aime bien faire ça je les fais avec
les médecins j'en ai eu 20 minimes avec
les infirmiers andy 40000 les hyades
4500 les étudiants pas loin de dix mille
et qui n'est pas loin de dix mille
j'ai réuni tous les pc m e j'ai réuni
tous les directeurs d'établissements
hospitaliers j'en ai eu 1400 donc j'aime
bien fonctionné comme ça ça permet
souvent de lever des incompréhensions en
direct avec les corps intermédiaires
dont contrat avec tessa charme l'action
du statut elle est compliquée parce que
alors il ya aussi une mission qui est en
cours mais il faut savoir si on donne le
statut
un statut ou l'autre comme les à
l'hôpital en fait on peut pas avoir les
deux statues et d'ailleurs les syndicats
que j'ai vu les centrales syndicales me
disent plutôt la même chose on va faire
évoluer le métier ça choque et n'arrête
pas d'évoluer dans le bon sens on leur
donne de plus en plus de missions
consultation ville vaccination bientôt
libéré instrumentale en tout cas c'est
en discussion au parlement dit ah on va
continuer je vraiment c'est une
profession que j'affectionne en plus
donc croyez moi je les oublie pas
occultant affirmé oui c'est un sujet
dont on augmente le nombre de places de
formation pour les infirmiers on
modernise et on construit des ifsi en
est avec les régions au pouvoir
stabiliser les choses être plus
attractif pour les sénatrices manier
donc j'ai répondu sur le périmètre du c
ur sur les oubliés du ségur là donc je
vais je reprends pas la réponse
sur l'essai pts structuration par les
ars bof bof je préfère que ce soit les
professionnels eux-mêmes qui se
structure on n'est pas obligé d'avoir
systématiquement le regard de
l'administration des technostructures
parce que ça se passe bien mais
évidemment il ya un regard de la rs et
un accompagnement par la rs c'est
important donnez un état des lieux
chiffré il actuellement 137 cpts en
fonctionnement 584 pts en projet 1740
maison de santé pluriprofessionnelle et
j'ai oublié mes derniers chiffres mais
pardonnez moi pour le sénateur iacobelli
sur la télémédecine j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on est on est monté on a fait un
bond de dix mille à un million de
téléconsultation par semaine prise en
charge à 100% par l'assurance maladie
faisable par skype par watt âmes parce
que vous voulez j'ai autorisé pour les
kinés pour les infirmiers et ça ça a
vraiment boosté à booster le truc on est
redescendu à un niveau un peu plus un
peu moins élevé qu'un million enfants
n'aient plus à plusieurs centaines de
milliers des négociations
conventionnelles sont en cours pour
ancrer dans le cadre conventionnel un
certain nombre de dispositions et
discussions en cours je sais que
certains syndicats voulaient conserver
une consultation téléphonique ce qui est
pas trop la bible assurance maladie etc
c'est pas trop la ligne construit par
contre développer le numérique à fond
oui et en pratique qu'est ce que c'est
la télémédecine demain c'est pas des
grands groupes qui vont salariés des
médecins qui ont faire des consultations
à la chaîne depuis jeunes 16 ou pas ça
c'est prenez un copain qui surgit un
orthopédiste qui me disait que en fait
depuis la crise il a conservé une
habitude il a une demi journée par
semaine de téléconsultation et une
petite mamie de 85 ans qui devait se
taper 50 minutes d'ambulances faire
attendant salles d'attentes se
déshabiller être examinés et repartir
chez elle avec de l'ambulance et c'est
ce qui coûtait très cher et lui ai dû
coûter beaucoup de temps en fait dans un
certain nombre de situations le
chirurgien à la radio de contrôle
interroge la patiente et voit qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de lui faire un
examen public en propre et donc tout le
monde gagne du temps et a donc ça c est
en train de rentrer progressivement
comme ceux d'hier est un plus dans le
dans le quotidien du médecin qui le
souhaitent d'ailleurs personne n'est
forcé à le faire mais on voit que le
nombre de médecins qui ont adhéré à cela
à augmenter fortement
et ce sera également le cas pour ce sera
également le cas pour d'autres
professions médicales on peut développer
beaucoup en zone rurale aussi avec des
cabines de téléconsultation il ya
beaucoup de projets qui sont en cours et
ça le ségur du numérique doit permettre
aussi dernière
dernière salve de questions dominique
théophile qui à distance
dominique que théophile aujourd'hui
n'est-ce pas question pas concerné le
déploiement des projets territoriaux de
santé
le titre ii vise notamment à promouvoir
des projets territoriaux de santé dans
le but de décloisonner de l'offre de
soins entre le public et le privé est un
faux l'hôpital et les soins de ville
mans et de mieux structurer l'offre de
soins dans les territoires au bronze que
pouvez vous nous dire de leur
déploiement et leur oncle l'objectif
aujourd'hui viser la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat avait
souligné le risque de tomber si fication
c'est une mesure de simplification
nouvelle paradoxalement fait planer sur
notre système de santé dit aujourd'hui
de son efficacité et de la vision de
passionnant la présente monsieur mini
jeux vous parlez de santé au travail
alors je sais que vous n'êtes pas le
seul concerné que l interministériel
j'espère vous me direz pas que ça
concerne d'autres ministères parce que
de mon point de vue ça concerne le
gouvernement et au premier chef le
ministre et la santé connaissent et la
démographie médicale en médecine du
travail entre 2015 et 2019 c'est moins
10% le médecin du travail et à la
proposition de loi dont nous avons raté
texte ce matin en commission des
affaires sociales prévoit justement la
possibilité permettre aux médecins de
ville de contribuer au suivi de l'état
de santé des travailleurs quel est votre
sentiment sur cette mesure
suffira-t-elle selon vous à résoudre le
manque de ressources en médecine du
travail même si c'est pas forcément sens
à l'objectif et plus fondamentalement
cette fois-ci et qu'elle pourrait être
selon vous les moyens qui permettraient
de renforcer l'attractivité de la
spécialité de la médecine du travail
seriez-vous favorable par exemple à ce
qu'on permette à des étudiants en
médecine de réaliser leur stage
obligatoire au sein d'un service de
santé au travail avant la réalisation du
deuxième cycle est ce qui serait
envisageable par exemple donc cursus
aujourd'hui 10 passes s avant-hier mais
on n'en parle plus maintenant d'intégrer
notamment des modules de santé au
travail le plus tôt possible dans les
cursus universitaires de en études de
médecine pour permettre justement une
sensibilisation et une meilleure
attractivité parce que certains
découvrent très tardivement la
spécialité de médecine du travail qui
est une spécialité à part entière et que
beaucoup dont nous faisons partie au
sénat il murray voir perdurer et être
renforcé avec le temps je vous remercie
daniel chassaing de madame la présidente
monsieur ministre donc moi je
c'est humain je me réjouis que le prêt
du gouvernement est donnée 183 euros par
mois aux soignants s'est jamais
suffisant mais c'est un peu plus
important laurent simplement les maisons
d'accueil spécialisées que je connais
n'ont pas de nouvelles des foyers
occupationnels c'est le département
n'ont pas de nouvelles le cd non plus et
les im non plus dans ce que je connais
donc si vous voulez c'est pour ça qu'on
reçoit effectivement des personnels et
nos permanences deuxièmement des en ce
qui concerne en ce qui concerne le
projet de loi qui a été acceptée par
sénat et l'assemblée nationale qui a
décrit corinne imbert
donc c'est un amendement qui est devenu
un amendement de la commission et moi
gérons j'étais aux côtés d'un ami ans
quand il a reçu des internes
au départ c'était un an puis après on a
négocié
j'étais là six mois et c'était
obligatoire en dernière année de
troisième cycle mais ça peut être
changée à l'assemblée nationale j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas c'est resté
comme ça
et monsieur le ministre quand vous
parlez des 400 vous confondez avec ma
santé 2022 ou madame busards avait dit
il y aura 400 praticiens qui iront dans
les hôpitaux périphériques et qui rondes
dans les zones sous denses
enfin je termine en ce qui concerne les
choix non programmés votre secrétaire
d'état m'a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire de soins non programmés sans un
hôpital périphériques je suis désolé je
pense qu'avec des maisons de santé et
d'essai pts on peut avoir des maisons de
santé de garde à tour de rôle est de
faire et faire également des soins non
programmés
enfin la situation dans certains
départements ruraux est complètement
catastrophique
malgré que on est des maîtres de stage
dans nos cabinets en fait quand les
étudiants sont internes et bien ils ont
choisi déjà leur lieu d'implantation
puisque dans mon cabinet ça fait à peu
près dix ans qu'on est maître de stage
et on n'a jamais eu un seul interne qui
finalement s'est installé en attente
j'ai trouvé une remplaçante
mais je ne trouve pas de ce qui me
concerne par exemple de deux rangs passe
est obligé de s'arrêter plusieurs mois
elle aura pas de remplaçant j'oublie g22
de la remplacer et je vous avais écrit
plusieurs fois alors quatre fois pour
avoir des informations en ce qui
concerne d pad ou puisque j'avais une
panne ou qu'ils étaient d'accord pour
venir chez moi je sais que vous avez eu
beaucoup de problèmes avec le co ville
mais je n'ai toujours pas eu de
répondant je me permets de vous le dire
les praticiens à diplôme hors union
européenne
c'est pas du
laurence rossignol ensuite j'en sors
jean marie vanlerenberghe inondés sous
le nom c'est c'est du four on aura
permis une seat monde écrit merci madame
la présidente je voulais vous interrogez
monsieur le ministre sur les assises de
la santé mentale qui ont été reporté de
juin à septembre et personnes vous en
fait le procès on imagine bien quelles
ont été les raisons pour autant mais
c'est pas une affaire qui s'est joué sur
trois mois ça signifie que ces
conclusions pourront difficilement être
suivies d'effet et mise en oeuvre avant
la fin du quinquennat
parce que les négociations et les
discussions vont être longues
aussi après les assises mais ma question
était c'est simple c'est qu'est ce que
vous en attendez quel est votre projet
en la matière et comment vous allez
garantir la dimension pluridisciplinaire
de la santé madame en talent et en
particulier l'articulation entre eux
psychiatres et psychologues et
médico-social gens seuls inquiétez pas
très simple la question gens seuls
bonjour chargé de repos sur la mission
sur la sur la santé mentale avec les que
madame gesnot j'ai une question à vous
poser les médecins et chercheurs
rencontrés lors de nos auditions ont mis
en évidence des effets importants de la
crise sanitaire et des mesures
sanitaires sur le niveau des cadences
idc vélo notamment ou de symptômes
dépressifs dans la population générale
avec en particulier chez les femmes les
troubles alimentaires en plus nombreux
chez les jeunes de moins de 15 ans le
gouvernement assure at il suivi
épidémiologique des conséquences de la
crise sur la santé mentale des français
si l'on espère que ces troubles
constatés ne seront que temporaires
quelle moyenne le gouvernement met fin
fils en place pour assurer une prise en
charge de premier niveau à d'intérêt à
ce public particulier et potentiellement
massifs ces objets de ma première
question
la seconde concerne monsieur le ministre
les personnels de réanimation en bas
lle qui revendique aujourd'hui ubi
j'aurais souhaité avoir votre avis sur
sur leurs préoccupations et surtout sur
leur demande compte tenu de leur
mobilisation de leur implication et de
leur disponibilité notamment lors de
cette crise sanitaire qui
malheureusement n'est pas encore terminé
[Musique]
quasi absolu ministre trois questions à
ces brèves que pensez-vous du numéro
d'urgence dont il est fortement question
aujourd'hui de le rendre unique
deuxièmement concernant les espic c'est
un sujet qui est permanent d'alignement
des modalités d'exercice du privé
d'exercice privé plutôt de la médecine
des explique sur le public et troisième
question ça concerne la médecine
scolaire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez un vrai
sujet sur le mini c'est que il ya qu un
médecin pour 12000 elle il manque de
médecins donc il manque effectivement de
deux consultations de suivi des élèves
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que la
télé qu'on le développement la
téléconsultation avec des généralistes
quand il y en a de disponible ce ne
serait pas la solution est allé et
maintenant pour terminer monsieur dufour
merci merci dans le président monsieur
le ministre je vous posais des questions
relativement simples et courtes
alors comme vous l'a demandé d'ailleurs
notre collègue de plusieurs collègues
certains professions médicales brand et
des exclus ou écartés du ségur hemayma
était là posé la question par des
médecins à l'oncopôle de toulouse qui
comme vous le savez sur le terrain nous
organisons beaucoup de prévention
également de traitement edmond indique
effectivement ne pas faire partie du
service de la santé
je voulais savoir quel était votre
position sur ce prix merci ministre je
vous le dis avec toute l'amitié et toute
la passion que je peux avoir pour le
système de santé
vous pouvez me reprocher beaucoup de
choses mais pas de être un passionné de
ces questions là je vais pas faire un un
grand oral sur la médecine scolaire la
médecine du travail ou la santé mentale
je crois que c'était pas trop l'objet de
la convocation de votre commission j'ai
déjà beaucoup débordé on a parlé de
vaccination de beaucoup de choses mais
la voilà on jeu il y aurait beaucoup de
choses à dire mais là c'est sûr les sur
les projets de territoriaux de santé
il n'y a pas encore de bilan
formellement j'ai beaucoup parlé des
projets de santé à travers le notamment
les cps tout à l'heure c'est pts tout à
l'heure sachez que pour les biens non je
parle à un vélo c'est pas grave pour un
an du ségur on aura plus d'informations
chiffrées et que on travaille beaucoup
pour le lien à créer du lien renforcé le
lien entre le cpt a cédé j'ai acheté
décès pts et le domaine de la santé
mentale pour
je ne sais plus c'était monsieur ou
madame à stan au pardon je monsieur à
stan au pardon en face au bout d'une
heure et demie je vous prie de m'excuser
mais j'aurais eu 40 questions donc au
bout de la 30e jeu baisse un peu
original
monsieur le sénateur artano je ne ferai
donc pas tous chapitre sur les métiers
du travail mais j'ai des petites idées
sur comment renforcer l'attractivité
sujet si j'avais reçu députés quand
j'étais rapporteur général de la
commission à l'assemblée nationale
l'irrigation de métal travail et j'ai
compris que le sujet n'était pas la
rémunération ni la qualité de travail
par contre j'avais peut-être des
éléments qu'on pouvait revoir notamment
dans l'accès les voies d'accès la
médecine du travail quand vous êtes un
médecin généraliste vous avez 55 ans
mais soigné des familles entières et qui
vont vous tapiez quatre ans d'internât
où tu sais plus combien ou faisant
fonction d'interné métiers du travail
pour faire de la prévention etc
je sais pas si ça figure dans le texte
veut pas dire de bêtises et j'ai une
solidarité gouvernementale totale mais
sachez que je pense que la
simplification de l'accès les métiers du
travail et les voies communicants entre
les vases communicants entre un retour
un exercice ormes et il travaille et
c'est ça c'est pour moi le sujet numéro
un
j'ai eu mes row 2 c'est peut-être cette
perte systématique de la capacité
prescrire mais quand vous êtes un
médecin généraliste
il y en a quelques-uns ici j'ai bien
compris cap et il y en a quelques-uns si
j'ai bien compris que vous perdez du
jour au lendemain la capacité de
prescrire parce que vous devenez médecin
du travail
ça fait partie des petites choses qu'on
peut changer rien où je pense que c'est
on compterait plus facilement bref pour
le sénateur chassa il ya un travail
aussi à faire de notre part certainement
mais aussi à travers la part des
fédérations d'information de leurs
mandants sûr quand une bénéfice du ségur
parce que parmi les lis que la vie ce
que vous m'avez fait tout alors
allemands y en a un certain nombre qui
font évidemment partie des bénéficiaires
du ségur donc je ne peux pas appeler les
quinze mille établissements
médico-sociaux sociaux et sanitaires
pour leur dire abandonné il ya un devoir
d'information aussi mais j'entends bien
que tout ça va se doit se clarifier ce
sera qu'à bientôt les soins non
programmés sont possibles dans l'essai
pts je vous le confirme
ça fait même partie des missions de ces
pts pour la sénatrice rossignol
rossignol donc qu'elle songeait pas à
faire j'étais tout le panel de mais il
ya déjà plusieurs objectifs
l'objectif démographique on manque
cruellement de psychiatre à l'hôpital la
filière de pédopsychiatrie est une
filière qui est totalement pulvérisées
j'ai vu le plus de la plus grande estime
pour les pédopsychiatres qui continue
d'exercer parce qu'ils sont de moins en
moins nombreux donc leur métier de plus
en plus difficile et il s'accroche
il faut absolument les soutenir je veux
absolument qu'on fasse quelque chose
pour les psychologues et notamment le
psychologue en vivent
parce que on sait très bien qui a pas
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de scènes et
qui tourne grâce aux psychologues il
faut reconnaître cela c'est pas simple
et il faut mettre tout le monde d'accord
je le dis d'emblée un psychologue en
libéral il peut pas à la fois être
remboursés
avoir une bonne revalorisation des
tarifs de consultation ne pas être
prescrits et fonctionnant en totale
autonomie sens et de professions de
santé
alors parlons pas remis et certaines
revendications il ya celle ci qu'il se
cumulent et je suis sûr que si je vous
proposais sénat vous me diriez que je
suis je suis je suis dingue donc il faut
évidemment qu'on garde et outils par
contre qu'on est con utilisent davantage
les psycho moi je suis partisan de ça
quand j'étais neurologue à l'hôpital
j'ai embauché une psychologue à mi-temps
pour faire l'accompagnement
thérapeutique des patients atteints de
sclérose en plaques y avait pas de
budget parce qu'ils ne produisent pas
d'acte à l'hôpital c'est pas une
profession de santé en tant que tel d'où
le projet sur de la revalorisation des
grilles etc et vous avez encore certains
représentants je n'ai pas tous mais
certains représentants qui ne veulent
pas que les psychologues soient
prescrits ils veulent pas une
intégration haddock dans le parcours de
soin c'est pas le cas tous encore une
fois je dis ça parce que sinon on va
encore me bombarder de messages
injurieux sur twitter je parle je dis ce
que je pense
j'ai toujours fonctionné comme ça donc
les gens du coup je veux pas que les
gens se sentent blesser ou stigmatiser
mais il ya encore certaines personnes
considèrent qu'un psychologue il doit
être en dehors de tout
car il y en a d'autres qui disent mais
nous on a envie d'avoir une intégration
donc je veux qu'on puisse travailler à
cela qu'on puisse travailler aussi à
réformer la formation professionnelle si
c'était nécessaire des psycho et des
programmes parce qu'il ya encore des
psychiatres certains pas tous mais
certains psychiatres me disent les
psychologues sont pas formés comme il
faut pour faire le métier de soins comme
il faut on attendait les amis ils sont
formés en 5 ans s'il ya un problème de
formation on revoit les choses mais
voilà il faut qu'on fasse ce qu'on crée
plus eu plus de choses comme ça à
l'accompagnement aussi la reconnaissance
sociale
il ya beaucoup de si beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut aborder au cours de ces
assises merci d'avoir reconnu que dans
la période c'était très compliqué de
d'enchaîner directement juillet avec ça
ça fait le lien avec sur le sur la santé
mentale est ce qu on fait un suivi de
l'impact de la crise évidemment qu'on va
faire un suivi on le fait on a des
indicateurs sur la dépression sur
l'anxiété on voit une amélioration la
tue pas les chiffres depuis trois
semaines mais des trois semaines envoyé
une amélioration d'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs d'état de santé mentale ce
qui va avec le déconfinement on n'est
pas revenue à la normale en cornes on
suit ça de près en naîtra personne sur
le bord du chemin sur le numéro unique
moi j'ai compris que le débat était
derrière nous parce que vous allez être
amenée à examiner la ppl dit matras
pompiers qui prévoit la possibilité
d'expérimenter dans un territoire donné
une alternative au saas mais il ya une
vingtaine de sas qui sont aussi
déployées sur le territoire national qui
remporte un engouement assez assez
favorable donc je joue on ne l'est pas
on va pas retenir une solution unique
pour un numéro unique
c'est plutôt le début le déploiement moi
je crois beaucoup déploiement du saas
mais c'est normal je représente la santé
mais si je discute avec d'autres il
reprit ils reconnaîtront que numéro
unique est important je pense que le
débat il juste et qu'on a trouvé je
pense vous serez amené à voter un point
d'équilibré assez sexy sur la question
la médecine scolaire donc je rentre pas
parce que j'en ai pas le jean n'est pas
le périmètre c'est jean michel blanquer
ministre de la santé scolaire puisque
c'est le personnel de santé scolaire et
de l'éducation nationale et j'ai même
peur que si je commençais à parler de la
santé scolaire dans cette enceinte ça
fasse ça puisse prêter à l'idée que
l'amitié
serai demain rapatrier la santé on va
parler ça dans la loi cadré mais c'est
je pense que ce sera le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui sera qui sera
au banc j'ai évidemment beaucoup de
choses à dire mais je vous avais invité
de mise à santé et pour le pour les skis
je suis un peu de votre question sur les
espy que c'était sur la ligne mantes et
à la revalorisation des poids des
patients médicaux des médecins
bah oui maison ils l'ont perçu 1 ouais
ils ont ils écrit lcc expliquent ils ont
eu tous les salariés ont une revalo
médecins hospitaliers dépassements
d'honoraires ils sont pas autorisés ah
oui ça c'est un vrai sujet c'est hors
ségur ça le temps là dans le coup dans
la loi puis dans le plfss
vous avez voté une disposition qui
permet aux ex aux cubaines rattachés aux
explique de leur médecin des
exploitations explique de faire du de
l'activité libérale qui solutionne un
certain nombre de deux problèmes
et puis sénateur dufour set j'ai marqué
ségur et après j'ai une écriture de
médecins j'écris juste après je sais si
c'était surtout sur kg et eric 1
voilà reposer votre question à propos de
phishing dans le cadre d secure
effectivement des médecins de l'oncopôle
de toulouse dans epic ne pas ne pas
avoir été dix ans bénéficiaire de ce ca
du pacifique dont le problème au 1er
juin ils l'ont lu donc leur posez leur
la question ils l'ont eu mais ces
récents seuls intérêts de respect qu'ils
ont eue au 1er juin
c'est cela oui mais la question avait
été posée il ya deux ou trois membres
oui non mais c'est et moi on avait 10
correspondant la question on a on a fait
leur valorisation
ce serait un mais c'est pas faute
d'avoir insisté le ministre et moi je
suis partie sur ma lancée si vous avez
encore 50 questions à poser
on a eu chaud sinon je vous remercie
pour votre orientation
merci monsieur mini serait qu on aurait
plein de questions à poser mais bon
c'est quand même été très raisonnables
dans ses limites et je rejoins la
demande
il avait dû à nous qu'on est quand même
quelque chose d'assez clair sur ce
qu'est la revalorisation des césures et
puis une clarification quand même sur
les carrières à mon sens la réplication
sur les carrières font qu'on est
vraie vision des choses et une
tarification par rapport à l'amendement
que porte et corinne inverse sur les les
étudiants en médecine les sur le texte
qu'on soit aussi bien clair là dessus et
voilà
[Musique]